foreign
body camera video shows what led up to
an officer-involved shooting in Texas
after a suspect was found firing a gun
in a public park
the incident happened on March 29th in
San Antonio that's when a 9-1-1 call
came in for a person firing a weapon out
in public
police there's a kid and a guy in Arnold
Park he's shooting a gun he's got long
black hair uh Black Backpack black
Jackie she's wearing pants body camera
video shows officers responding to the
shooting in progress call asking passers
by whether they've seen the suspect
y'all hear anything yeah he's right
there in the vent where where which one
Straight Ahead straight ahead
foreign
after that officers find the suspect
later identified as 26 year old Raul
arzola in the middle of a field they
approach and call for him to drop the
weapon when arzola draws his weapon
toward officers they opened fire that's
our place I miss your hands let me see
your hands let me see your hands
here's the shooting from another angle
ran off after the shooting body camera
video shows officers track him down and
call for him to get to the ground
get down
our Zola was later taken to the hospital
and treated for his injuries no one else
was injured in the shooting our Zola now
faces multiple charges including
aggravated assault with a deadly weapon
the shooting is now under investigation
by the Bexar County District Attorney's
Office reporting for long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie